so we just introduced you to one of the
remaining people here
tell me why you're still here at this
time oh we're still here
standing here for our liberties you know
we're not going to let them um
i think that they're going to bully us
out of an election
you know a lot of people here believe
that donald trump won uh
and that there's evidence to prove it
but you know
and as much as people will dispute that
and say
actually it was a fair election and joe
biden won
credibly um do you think that this is
a good way of making your point um maybe
not to the extent of you know breaching
the
the capitol building but of course you
know standing out here and protesting
as long as it's peaceful i believe that
that's a
that's the the main thing now someone
who was here
attending the protest today has lost
their life uh
in what happened yeah i've been informed
do you feel that
donald trump's uh language
has incited some of this this violence
you say that
you should be here and be peaceful do
you think he's his language has been
responsible
um i mean
i believe that he's been i guess
responsible because of course you know
he
endorses the police and you know he
enforces law and order
um so of course you know and i believe
also
there was a tweet earlier from him
saying to remain peaceful and
you know do you think that made a
difference i believe for some people it
does
but of course you know then there's
others that you know don't in the heat
of the moment they don't take that into
consideration